- Elle trône au sommet
de l'Europe; la Suisse, avec c s
et ses glaciers. Un paysage
en train de changer plus
rapidement qu'anticipé.
♪ ♪ ♪
Jérémie et Bertrand Gentizon
sont tous deux guides de
montagne, une véritable passion
familiale. Le père est
spécialiste de biogéographie,
le fils termine ses études
en glaciologie.eeeeeeeeeeeeeeeee
montagne, étudiant glaciologie
- Pour nous, mon papa et moi,
c'est un endroit qu'on apprécie
vr
on est venu souvent pour faire
de l'alpinisme, pour faire
de la randonnée. C'est super
intéressant parce qu'on peut
de l'ampleur des changements,
de l'impact de la hausse des
températures sur les glaciers.
♪ ♪ ♪
d'arriver au pied du glacier
du Mont Miné. Au fil des
générations, ce géant a perdu
de son immensité. En 60 ans,
de longueur.
Un recul qui se const
année après année.
BERTRAND GENTIZON, guide
montagne, spécia. biogéographie
- Ça me bouleverse.
à l'identité de cette montagne
que j'ai appris à connaître.
Je dois aussi quand même,
ça me fend le coeur de voir ça.
C'est très impressionnant ce qui
est en train de se passer par dl
j'ai grandi ici, se transforme
à une vitesse que je ne pouvais
pas imaginer possible
♪ ♪ ♪
- Le phénomèststst loin d'être
unique. Cette année seulement,
6 % de leur superficie.
Deux à trois fois plus que
ce qui avait été constaté
Trop peu de neige en hiver
pour protéger la glace
et des chaleurs records en été,
- J'ai même vu même des photos
et on voit carrément une langue
de glace qui a disparu.
- Le photographe Hilaire
la fonte des glaciers.
Pendant plusieurs années,
il a parcouru les Alpes,
(clic)
Sa mission : comparer les décors
que l'on voyait il y a
des dizainess s s s s s s s s s.
HILAIRE DUMOULIN, photographe
- Je trouve ça important
de montrer ce qui se passe,
parc
dit pas grand-chose. Les plus
anciennes photos que j'ai,
elles sont de 1848. Et on peut
dire que durant ces 150 ans,
ce que ce qui s'est passé.
Et puis la réalité, c'est
que c'est vrai que les glaciers
sont en train de disparaître.
certains de ses secrets.
Ces dernières an, , , épaves
et corps disparus depuis
longtemps ont ét
Le phénomène a aussi
des répercussigégégéopolitiques.
La fonte d'un glacier dans
les Alpes a
la ligne de partage des eaux,
démarcatiotututurelle entre
la Suisse et l'Italie. Les deux
pays o
de négocier le tracé de leur
frontière.
À moyen ou long terme, le recul
des glaciers pourrait aussi
de la Suisse. Un pays dont les
paysages alpatatattirent chaque
année plus de 10 millions
de touristes.
Université de Zurich
- Les glaciers svrvrvraiment
très, très importants pour le
tourisme. Mais il y a aussi
Parce que, en Suisse, l'énergie
hydroélectriesesest très, très
importante et la plupart de
l'eau pour l'énergie hydraulique
Ça veut dire quand les glaciers
fondent, les barrages sont moins
remplis et là, il aura sûrement
des conséquences sur la
production hydroélectrique.
- Au fil de ses études,
le chercheur Matthias Huss
de l'université de Zurich a vu
d'immenses glaciers diminuer
en longueur et épaisseur.
Les recherches ont même cessé
sur de plus petits glaciers,rer.
Selon lui, le phénomène,
qu'il attribue entre autres
climatiques, a de quoi inquiéter
au-delà des frontières suisses.
-
comme le château d'eau de
l'Europe. Les plus grands
Alpes. Et comme ça, ils viennent
des glaciers. Et la disparition
des glaciers aura sûrementz z ze
sur nos fleuves.
- C'est vraiment l'arc alpin
qui est en train de perdre
son caractère de château d'eau.
C'est l'arc alpin qui est
en train de voir son identité
glaciaire disparaître. Toutes
ces itinéraires glaciaires qu'on
a parcouru pendant trois,
quatre, cinq générations,
ils sont en train de disparaître
eux aussi.
PoPoPour des guides expérimentés
comme Bertrand et Jérémietetetes
vient avec le besoin
de s'adapter. Danger lié aux
chutes de pierres et naissance ,
il faut revoir fréquemment
le trajet des randonnées.
- Maintenant, le processus,stste
chose contre lequel, même
si on stoppait les émissions
de gaz à effet de serrentntntnt,
il continuerait. Mais ce qu'on
peut faire nous, c'est déjà
prendre conscience de ce qui
des changements, essayer
de chercher pourquoi
ces changements ils ont lieu.
Donc, prendre conscience en fait
une partie centrale du problème.
Et puis travailler làsususus.
- En Suisse, en France
et en Italie, des efforts
Comme l'installation de
couverture de ececection
sur les glaciers.
- Il y a vraiment des blocs,
parce qu'il y en a qui suspendu
là, , , en haut.
- Mais vu la vitesse à laquelle
les Gentizon ont assisté à cette
les perspectives sont peuencours
prochaines générations.
- Je me sens assez chanceuxs à ,
parce que je me dis bien que
les prochaines générations,
peut-être dans 20 ans, quinze
ans, elles auront pas  m m m m .
Donc moi, je suis tellement dans
ce changement puis je l'encre
dans ma mémoire. Comme ça,
je pourrais le l l l l l l l l i